this program is brought to you by
Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia.edu one time she said I'm
nervous but I'm calm centered and
balanced and I know all of you I was
story to tell and I told it to another
friend this morning and approximately
I'd say roughly the year was about 1910
a Native American woman gets up in the
middle of the night she's been summoned
she lives in North using South Carolina
it's cold but she knows she has to go
she goes to her barn and hitches up a
mule the exact and she tells salad and
have a baby to deliver and Sal who seems
to understand her when she speaks to him
let's stance quietly watching hitches
him up to her little buggy and out she
goes into the night she has a will that
most people use on their animals of
horses or mules that are pulled in
advances at the time but she never he
needs to use it she goes to a lady's
house and again this woman delivered as
a baby she has never lost a baby she has
never lost the mother in all her years
of doing this she goes back for another
seven days while this mother rest she
takes
or maybe she cleans her house she
teaches her about childcare she washes
her clothes that wound was my
grandmother my name is Ellen lam butler
she's born in eighteen seventy five
she's a native american woman she's
community health educator sean goes by
his friends house early in the morning
they're both Vietnam War vets tells us
friend who has diabetes I know does not
ask him he says to them I know you've
taken your medication this morning and
you checked your blood sugar his friend
answer's no I forgot but he says now
remember your nurse told you to do that
and said yeah you're right i guess i
should should not yank should so the
friend takes his blood Sugar's writes it
down and takes his medications the man
who comes into the house john is a
community health worker person he spoke
to was a patient of mine okay how do we
switch this thing
come on ty okay what is a community
health educator or community peer
educator well according to the Center
for Disease Control community health
educators work exclusively in community
settings they must the side of the
communities in which they work they must
understand the language the culture what
is meaningful to the members of that
community they serve as a linkage to the
health care system for those underserved
members of their community and they may
also educate a provider on what the
community needs as well as assist with
cultural competence
come on
these are the standing rules for
community health educators according to
Wiggins and Borman they bridge cultural
mediations in communities and healthcare
system again and provide culturally
appropriate and accessible health
education and information they are sure
that people get the services they need
sound so like my grandma going back to
wash clothes our baby care for madam eat
fish provide information or informal
counseling and social support like John
going to encourage his friend to take
his meds they activate the individuals
and communities within the health or
social service system and they provide
direct services such as basic first aid
they built individual and community
capacity so those are some ideas of what
a community educators should be doing
now that we've ascertained that let's
get back to the main topic what is
diabetes sure you've all heard of it by
now if you haven't heard from it in your
classes and on TV and if you know me
you've heard about it for me diabetes is
a disease associated with high levels of
blood sugar resulting from defects in
insulin productivity closet sugar to
build up in the body is the seventh
leading cause of death in the country it
is finally acknowledged as being a cause
of death previously they would
person died of an informed person died
on stage renal disease they never
discussed what this was secondary to now
diabetes is listed on the certificates
of death these are the types of diabetes
i pretty much encounter and my practices
and people to pre-diabetes the fasting
blood sugar levels are between 100-125
type 1 diabetes what's called juvenile
diabetes the pancreas of this person is
with this conditional woman manufactures
insulin oh by the way that isn't that
type 2 dot kind of one guy abused can
come one at any time like my deck game
is diagnosed the edge there at the type
1 type 2 this is the one we see most of
95 excessive african-americans with
Diamonds happen once thought to occur
only in the elderly pancreas persons
with this condition does not produce
enough insulin and or their body cells
are resistant to using the insulin and
the liver allows excess glucose into the
bloodstream I put notice there that we
think it occur only in elderly we now
see very young children with type 2
diabetes
so I left slide in there these are what
we call the chronic conditions of
diabetes in other words product product
is something that wouldn't we get it
it's here to stay we can stop it from
getting worse but we can't make it go
away once the damage has been done we
have to live with it retinopathy I'll
just say it layman's terms imaging in
the back of the eyes can lead to
blindness net property layman's terms
kidney disease neuropathy layman's terms
nerve damage PVD referral vascular
disease clotting or blockages in the
lower limbs and legs that can lead to
amputation the third of the fourth go
hand in hand and they're one of highest
causes of amputation in the person
living with diabetes and of course
cardiovascular sequel I persons living
with diabetes are at the highest risk
for heart attacks and strokes okay so
diabetes now affects nearly 24 million
people in
states though what people are finding
out that they have it still it continues
to rise okay and I'll just go past that
slide now New York State it affects one
out of four every New Yorkers and that
number is done more than 1 million
diagnosed with it it is an estimated
that another forty forty or fifty
thousand of us will have diabetes don't
know if the symptoms may be overlooked
or misunderstood yes we all know are
some of us know about increased thirst
wounds that have a hard time healing
crease urination and some of us have no
symptoms at all people can walk around
with type 2 diabetes for up to 15 years
and not be diagnosed yet the damage is
being done
so this is how the cost of treatment
just completely otherwise you can see
the numbers there now that all the money
will be given to bail out the bags
everybody else I don't know we're going
to hit this money from okay because I'm
a Brooklyn night I'd like to talk about
my community this is my home community
board this is where I live this is where
I breathe this is why I play this is why
I work munity 43 the New York City
Department of Health of this this
community board as the highest has the
highest rates of obesity which is one of
the leading predictors for developing
diabetes now I walk the streets in this
community board keep your mic near the
mouth oh sorry doctor can you hear me
embed even hear me okay in this
community where I live there's a
mcdonalds that's four or five of them
within a walking right stop because it's
the truth with a range of my own home
there's a bodega what on this corner one
on the next corner and one other third
I'm just talked about on my blog the
food's there are pretty much cookies
cakes and these if there is milk it's I
back there's a lot of high-fat foods a
lot of process things that you can make
quickly in a microwave
it's not so good but nevertheless it's
their nutrition education is needed a
minority men the men that live in my
community are increased risk for
diabetes hypertension and prostate
cancer yet they don't go to the doctor
and they don't get these conditions
treated this talks about other areas of
Brooklyn also screaming for the same
health obesity continues to play
residents of the crown heights community
ocean hill Brownsville again we need
nutrition education in the community to
identify an assist persons we're not
eating properly and our risk for
becoming obese diabetes is on the rise
in this community we need services to
come back these health challenges okay
I'm sure you've heard about the loss of
mary immaculate and st. John's Hospital
in the Queen sections of New York have
not those two hospitals belong to a
massive corporation once known as
Catholic Medical Center's of New York
one of those hospitals was st. Mary's
Hospital of Brooklyn that I worked for
for about 10 11 years it was there
serving the community for approximately
hundred and twenty-three years it served
mostly people who had Medicaid Medicare
were uninsured underinsured people could
come from other countries and come
directly from Kennedy Airport to that
hospital and get services that Hospital
no longer exists it and it's six
satellite clinics that serve the
community no longer exists its sister
hospitals mary immaculate
and st. John's I'm sure you probably
might have seen st. John's that big
massive facility that was on this row is
a Queens Boulevard Queens Boulevard it
has been shocked to this community no
emergency room know what problems no
outreach clinics nothing is left no beds
these are some hospitals that have been
lost in Brooklyn Brooklyn Jewish
Hospital interfaith located on the
borderline of crown heights this is now
condos and co-ops if you've got the
money st. Mary's Hospital of Brooklyn
added six outreach clinics condos coops
a couple of the outreach clinics have
now become supermarkets food is not only
great IVA so I'm really disgusting whore
CC pack a small hospital and crown
heights condos that's just in Brooklyn
alone that was my saint Ares and I stole
this from the internet only because I
had to show everybody my little office
window and shovel at hall where I first
worked right there that big window right
there and that's where I worked and
started with program there mid years ago
it no longer exists a big six site with
Roman so this is a map of Brooklyn north
central Brooklyn can you see over there
bedford-stuyvesant Bushwick did you see
that crown heights brownsville those
areas of Roland have the highest
incidences
of diabetes and obesity and the
population there is below poverty in
many cases they're also African American
and Latino along with the loss of the
hospitals we've lost our diabetes
programs why popbytes hospital has lost
its diabetes program no longer exists
Brooklyn Moscow another major hospital
downtown Brooklyn has lost the Siberians
program due to funding Kingsbrook Jewish
Medical Center also another loss program
all services there for the community
that no longer exists now the way to
prevent diabetes is to have diet and as
to work on a healthy diet and have
exercised and this needs to start at a
young age so I can't relief though and
tell somebody like me in their forties
okay now you need to diet and exercise
yes I do but considering the fact that
type 2 diabetes weekend again as yelling
at two and three this needs to start at
a young age you need to start with the
parents now this picture i put here
because you see these two children here
and this precious child you see and
she's starting to get fat all ready or
should i say overweight the correct term
is pediatric overweight now it took me
40 years to get those roles and I think
I'm entitled to them at this point those
are not roles you should have at 10
didn't earn those roles yet ok now
prevention of the chronic complications
of diabetes we need a diet next
in a healthy way we need to do our blood
Sugar's if you already have diabetes we
need to maintain an a1c of less than
seven percent we need to get a blood
pressure of less than 130 over 80 we
need a cholesterol and LDL that we call
that the bad cholesterol needs to be
less than 100 and we need to take those
medications as prescribed okay this does
not always happen now here's where the
problems begin the present providers of
diabetes education are physicians
medical doctors doctor of osteopathic
medicine optometrists and they really
don't possess the time so many of them
just say do this and let the patient go
here's a bottle take the medication go
just do it old paradigm right just do it
don't have still nurses such as myself
nurse practitioners nurse specialists
and our ends physicians assistant these
are all the present providers now wait a
minute oh nevermind you fight with that
tie and I'll continue to talk all right
now what happens is that there is a
credential it's known as CDE have you
heard of it certified diabetes educator
that's when I am only doctors clinical
psychologists registered nurse
cational therapist pharmacist and
physical therapist or what I believe
social workers can become certified
diabetes educators and that's a problem
considering that we need more people out
there dietitians internet now to become
a certified diabetes educator you have
to have some experience unfortunately
this experience must be paid experience
you have to work once you finish your
licensure you have to work a minimum of
two years and must have minimum of
thousand hours and you must be employed
in other words you must be making a
salary in this position now they want
your salary to be commensurate with
other diabetes educators in the area in
which you live now for example the
average registered nurse certified
diabetes educator in New York City makes
between 85 thousand one hundred
twenty-five thousand dollars a year not
including purse what are perks speaking
engagements consulting for companies so
forth so on there's only one problem
that's not a lot of money you can't do
much with that money not today's economy
I don't know about you you can live on
that still a small organization that
wants to start a diabetes program may
not be able to afford that type of
salary so once all of that has been
completed and you managed to give the
correct salary and you manage to get a
job that's willing to let you be a
diabetes educator without being
certified then you can apply
take the exam and exam applications are
strict very strictly audited now that's
a problem because that means less
diabetes educators out there to do work
so who does it the American Diabetes
stand has decided that yes diabetes
educators well that would rather than be
certified yes they would rather than be
educated but and they must have recent
experience they keep on going and going
but I'll go to the next slide a few
minutes i'll stop here for a second and
say that this problem here and it i just
feel compelled to stop and talk about it
and break the slides the problem is that
when you become a diabetes educator the
hospital's want just certified people
they won't hire you unless you're
certified so they would rather not have
a diabetes program without a certified
professional so people don't get treated
even though that's my statement facility
is willing position if they do give it
to the mist attention upon passing
examine when your what if you don't pass
it please go to the bottom with all this
in mind the American Diabetes
Association has decided that they need
leg health and community workers appears
to provide information and support so
now we can get past the nurses and the
doctors and the dieticians and the
exercise physiologist etc etc and so
forth and we can go and have immunity
health educators and assist us in the
provision of care okay so these are some
competencies that was shared with me by
a colleague of mine that works in the
CDC we talked about the roles earlier
the person who's a peer educator just
needs to have a relationship with the
community community strength encourage
respectful these persist for systems
very important that you're willing to
persist you must be able to communicate
have knowledge which you can get past
the builtin be interpersonal be willing
to coordinate service be willing to
teach be willing to have it a be willing
to organize for your own community so
these are some examples of problems that
have used this concept one is the
Kentucky home place project the diabetes
partners in active action coalition
healing our village that term wellness
connections that's not our type own
there that's actually the way of spell
they started in October
Nate and their training medical
assistance to become diabetes educators
in the community very pleased with that
problem because I'm beginning to work
with them bedford-stuyvesant family
health care center this is from small
Center is providing diabetes education
to their patients and peer education and
one of the peer educators is now
teaching cooking for all the classes
that come along so in other words
they're taking traditional recipes and
making them lower in fat lower in
calories lower in sodium but still
delicious I'm very proud of this program
up where we okay this is another great
program this is a very in-depth program
this is the Indian Health Service
community health representatives
diabetes program this program the
training for their community health
educators may take up to a year and then
some months the training is ongoing and
they learn everything from cpr community
resources tribal customs health care
resources they even learn defensive
driving now I didn't understand the
concept of learning defensive driving
but I guess if you're driving a client
to see the doctor you're advocating for
them you never know ah this is my
favorite healthy families Arthur Ashe
Institute for Urban Health and long
island college hospital this
community-based program is wits just
started to do a great work in Brooklyn
their community health educators are
being trained to work in the projects
now the average person doesn't want to
visit somebody in a housing
project must let's go in there and help
somebody as I spent many years as a
homecare nurse in the past I know what
it's like to go in projects in New York
City sometimes they're dirty they're
cold they're scary the elevators out you
gotta walk 21 floors up to see old
ramrod on the top level and she must be
seen today what do you do Ross yourself
and woke up to 21 flights of stairs but
can you imagine mobilizing people who
live in that housing project on a daily
basis this can you imagine that they
live there they feel comfortable working
there they would be willing to do mark
wouldn't it
nicole say hey okay the leg is saying
hey is the deputy executive director of
the program that I just mentioned and
she called me some months ago and said
do me a favor now Nicole and I have
managed to work together over class 12
15 years 15 years in Brooklyn and we've
gone to again some of the dirtiness
coldest scariest hottest gunshot crack
houses etc in Brooklyn and we've done
community service together it's been an
amazing ride and she gave me at all
after all these years and said would you
be willing to teach some community peer
educators about diabetes so that they
can go out into the projects into the
housing areas on young men around and
help the people and I thought about it I
thought about the fact that I was
working and seeing a full patient load
for my own job and i was here at
columbia doing everybody's homework and
I needed to clean my house because if
you fall down in there right now you
will be lost for three years and I
really needed to do other things but I
thought about what she was saying and I
said I'll get back in touch with you and
then I went to my regular job and I saw
two people with no legs there were
recent activities secondary to diabetes
and I called them the call and said
where you want me to go and that's how
we started working together doing
diabetes community health educator
training in Brooklyn Sosa various
curriculums that are used are DMV
educate which is out of the universe
Pittsburgh diabetes self-management
education living with diabetes out of
the American Diabetes Association and
the National diabetes education program
in their power to prevent curriculum
endeavor is a collaborative between the
CDC and the NIH now that particular
curriculum is the one that I use so
we'll just go over briefly because i
think i have my five minutes left all
right and basically we cover an
introduction to our curriculum have a
small steps lead to big rewards
strategies for healthy eating now that's
hard some time in inner city community
so that in so we have to teach shopping
we have to teach some time cooking
recipe preparation and I don't know what
my other colleagues have found but I've
never seen so many young women and young
men that cannot cook a meal I'm all
right no I'm going to stop for two
seconds give me two extra minutes
because let me preach on this because I
would distinctly remember a forceful
Home Economics back in the day and you
had to learn how to cook you at least
have learned our boil water boy yourself
a pot of rice for yourself some hot
sauce do something people know how to go
to the microwave put a meal in it press
the button and get something out no one
can actually cook anymore so this next
go-round we're going to have to start
teaching cooking 101 good thing my
mother stood over me and made me learn
how to cook so my mother's from like I
said the sound and the way they dealt
with things back then is they taught you
how to cook
you took me off the family now your
family hated you knew he was ok but if
all of a sudden you saw them given
things to the family dog you know your
meal was bad and you had to get back in
the kitchen and work on it so that's
what we're going to work on we don't
want any more meat to the family dog
physical activity get moving today now
that is one of the hardest things to get
people to do something as simple as
walking with me the very thing but as
was mentioned yesterday sometime that's
dangerous so what you need is powering
the numbers walking groups need to be
established making healthy food choices
one day at a time again that goes back
to strategies for healthy eating one day
at a time also means that you know you
you're outside what do you eat when
you're out what do you do when you're
out ok i'm outside and burger king is
calling me do i go for the super-sized
walker or do i need a salad instead what
do i do diabetes overview i think i
talked about the a1c which is an
indicator i diabetes control blood
pressure which should be less than 130
over 80 and a cholesterol that should be
less of LDL should be less than 100 then
there's physical activities for families
we talked about starting young get those
little kids up from in front of the
intend oh the xbox the TV said the DVD
and get them to walk with you now of
course everybody's kids are the second
coming of some God and I've noticed that
lately I don't care even Mary and Joseph
told Jesus what to do at some point in
his life get him up say let's go they
need to move with you what is your
sizing this is easy in a simple
just cut your present portion sizes by
one-half that's all you don't need to
give up a portion or give up a food just
cut it by one-half and then they talked
about navigating around eating out now
this Nicole and I did we took our
clients or our students to bbq's we were
going to use bbq's and teach them how
they could get a great meal there so of
course they chose chicken they so salad
they chose a baked potato Nicole made me
send my chopped barbecue and coleslaw
back to the kitchen broke my heart but
you don't have to set an example my
exercise martini with back in favor of a
diet coke in water oh thank you love so
then the net lasting is partnering with
your health care provider the old
paradigm is dead you can talk we teach
our peer educators to tell their
patients you can talk to your healthcare
provider we're no longer called patients
anymore we're called clients and it's
why I can fire you can bag so that means
I tell them hey about notebook tell your
client to have a notebook they go inside
write down their questions and when the
doctor is done with his 15 minutes open
your mouth open your eyes okay i take
this description say told the doctor i
have some questions and then you ask
those questions and write down the
answers never we teach them to never let
a doctor tell you everything is okay
asking what okay means find out your
numbers and compare them up and you
celebrate big rewards now fifty percent
of my mother's children
diabetes I'm one of them and that
presents a problem from time to time
because I love to eat everything in
sight but I tell all of them and my
patients and my clients and the peer
educators there's something known as an
occasion there is a wetter depending
upon your culture it is there's some
occasion where you come together and you
eat we teach them if you watch your diet
on a daily basis then when that occasion
comes go ahead and enjoy yourself with
your family because it's not going to do
that much damage to you everybody's
allowed to live and when you give
somebody in leeway and tell them I
understand how you feel you're going to
get more I'm not going to use the term
compliance that I hate that word but
Lori adherence to the medical plan of
care and more participation in their own
care which is even more important I'm
going to stop now because last slides
pretty much talked about the Native
American community and a point that they
had but the point goes on to say I just
want to help my people what our future
our goals for Brooklyn and I assume all
of you are going to take this and go
with it are to not only have our
patients I'll have our excuse me wrong
term not only have our peer educators
become advocates we want them to do
point-of-care testing we want them to
help that
mother can't see check our blood sugar
we want them to take blood pressures we
want them to help help them check their
feet so that you will not have any more
negative outcomes and this is a hold on
one of my patients for you all that is
is a foot fungus that's a good fungus
now when you think of foot fungus should
think of athlete's feet little crack in
between the toes right a little itching
and going like this this is a woman
living with diabetes that's what a foot
fungus becomes for her perhaps if
someone could have gone to her and
worked with her and checked her feet for
her this would not have progressed to
this point I'm going to stop here oh he
says I've done this for question if any
who understood all that okay national
works diabetes education that's that's a
training for the educators and you can
get that for free
okay what I'm going to do is I'm going
to give you the website you can get that
greedy little for free its power to
prevent and end up and Rick ulam
many programs have them we're starting
to have ours it's needed so we want it
we want the training to be a little bit
more rigorous we want to empower them
and what's enough to know that they're
important so we're going to start to do
that kind of education yes that's our
work doesn't we're starting in Brooklyn
of the curriculum is taught by CDE so
all you have to do is get up over the
American Association of diabetes
educators and ask for CD in your area
and I'm sure they'll be very happy to do
it it is a CD who does the teaching as a
matter of fact in all of the cases
American Indians net which gives me
Native American associations the health
connections all of the curriculums are
taught by CDEs remember what I was
saying about CD he's being so hard to
come back so we need to get what ones
with the ones of cavity and put them to
work to create the community health
educators is that in Spanish that
particular curriculum is not but it can
be translated easily gee everybody
thanks
no no
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu